trying to comprehend how big the
universe is it's one of those questions
that astrophysicists grapple with all
the time trying to explain it in a way
that's easy to understand
well that's a whole other challenge
in 1977 Charles and Raye's hugely
influential American designers released
one of the most elegant and creative
pieces of science communication of
modern times powers of ten it took the
viewers on a journey from a picnic
blanket near Lake Michigan to the edge
of the known universe and back again
over 40 years later as a humble homage
to this groundbreaking film we're going
to take a similar Journey Through Time
and Space
and see how our understanding has
changed along the way as in 1977 we'll
start with a picnic though this time
we're on the island of Sicily in Italy
rather than Lake Michigan we'll start
with a scene one meter wide viewed from
one meter away and every 10 seconds
we're going to move out to 10 times
further away so the scene will be 10
times wider
this square is 10 meters wide and in 10
seconds the next Square will be 10 times
that the movement may seem linear but
we're actually accelerating
exponentially into the distance this
square is a hundred meters wide the
distance someone can run in 10 seconds
well if they're running at 43 kilometers
an hour just under the speed of your cat
one kilometer
though our picnickers are
indistinguishable now we can still
clearly see the impact of human activity
on the world
[Music]
ten thousand meters or ten to the four
meters this is the distance a supersonic
plane travels in 10 seconds and we're
now reaching the highest altitude flown
by such a plane ten to the 5 meters this
is the distance the International Space
Station travels in 10 seconds there it
goes from here on human activity will be
lost to sight we're at the scale of
countries one million meters or ten to
the six meters we've long left Earth's
atmosphere and soon we'll see the whole
planet what a jewel
10 million meters
the invisible magnetosphere Shields us
from the dangerous ionizing radiation of
space 10 to the 8 meters
this line extends at the speed of light
this is the time it takes for light to
reach us from the moon's orbits the age
of moonlight the Earth is now just a
pale blue dot in A Sky Full of Stars
even as we accelerate away
stars appear stationary because they're
so much further away so much empty space
let's illustrate the orbits of the
planets in our solar system otherwise
this could get a bit dull here comes the
orbit of Venus then Mars and now Mercury
since 2010 the NASA Solar Dynamics
Observatory has been using an extreme
ultraviolet filter to monitor the
activity of our sun finally we reach the
orbit of the outer planets the gas
giants but just specs at this distance
there's the orbit of Pluto one of the
dwarf planets of the Kuiper belt 10 to
the 13 meters and we're moving out of
the solar system in 2012 the Voyager 1
spacecraft became the first human
artifact to make this journey followed
in 2018 by its twin Voyager 2. both were
launched in 1977 the year the Eames were
working on Powers of Ten we're heading
into Interstellar space our certainly
just one of billions of stars and still
at this distance the night sky looks
very similar to what we see at home
this square is 10 to the 16 meters the
distance light travels in one year one
light year here's our closest neighbor
Alpha Centauri three stars for the price
of one with planets orbiting around them
I'd love to know what's going on there
thanks to data collected by the Gaia
spacecraft we're building a detailed 3D
map of the Milky Way There are between
100 and 400 billion stars in our galaxy
alone and clouds of dust and gas like
these nebula where new Stars Are Born
images sent from the Hubble Space
Telescope have been blowing our minds
for a generation as we move away we
begin to see the great flat spiral of
our galaxy a few hundred billion stars
rotating around a black hole Sagittarius
A star 4.2 million times more massive
than our sun we now think supermassive
black holes reside at the center of
nearly all galaxies these two dwarf
galaxies are the magellanic clouds which
together with at least 80 other make up
what's known as the local group of
galaxies 10 to the 22 1 million light
years soon we'll pass the super giant
elliptical galaxy m87 and if we switch
to radio waves we can Glimpse the
supermassive black hole at its Center
switching back to visible light as we
Traverse the Virgo supercluster each
tiny dot not a star but a Galaxy
billions of stars floating in an
ever-growing void 10 to the 24 meters
the limits of our vision in 1977 but
over 40 years later we can show a bit
more clusters of galaxies arranged along
filaments like the Pisces Sita
supercluster complex a 10 to the 26
meters we switch our view to microwave
and we can now see the current limit of
our vision this light forms a sort of
wall all around us the light and dark
patches show differences in temperature
by fractions of a degree revealing where
Mata was beginning to Clump together to
form the first galaxies shortly after
the big bang this light is known as the
cosmic microwave background radiation 10
to the 27 meters one followed by 27
zeros Beyond this point the nature of
the universe is truly Uncharted and
debated this light was emitted around
380 000 years after the big bang before
this time the universe was so hot that
it was not transparent to light is there
simply more Universe out there yet to be
revealed or is this region still
expanding generating more universe or
even other universes with different
physical properties to our own how will
our understanding of the universe have
changed by 2077
how many more Powers attempt are out
there from a picnic blanket on Sicily to
the very edge of our understanding I
salute the aims for the way they told
this beautiful story
story of the universe
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video